[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na arena seu
podcast semanal onde a gente di troc
conteúdos que a gente leu ouviu assistiu
sempre trazendo uma visão de produto pra
discussão eu sou o Artur e hoje estou
diretamente dos States eu sou a e
finalmente eu posso dizer que minha
mudança acabou duas semanas e meia
depois
fim Nossa Senhora cara nem me fale sobre
você sabe Enfim no programa de hoje você
vai ouvir a gente falar dos seguintes
assuntos as novidades da Meta o Lhama
novo o ran e a treta no Brasil com ai e
Netflix e a evolução do produto de vídeo
mas antes da gente ir pra paa tem Jabá
aí da semana sempre né Tem jeito de de
não ter
no último final de semana último sábado
agora rolou a terceira Edição do curso
de ai para PMs e foi legal ter gente
participando do mundo inteiro teve gente
participando aqui dos Estados Unidos
também além de mim mesmo e teve gente
até lá de Malta participando Olha aí e
um dado e um dado curioso aqui cara na
primeira edição do curso cerca de 30%
das pessoas a gente roda uma pesquisinha
Logo no início 30% só usavam ai
ou todo dia ou até uma vez por semana
agora na terceira Edição quase 90% das
das pessoas dos participantes
usavam entre todo dia e uma semana então
assim ai tá evoluindo né a gente fala
bastante aqui nos cursos mas é muito
legal de ver que a galera também tá
usando muito mais dia mão da galera né É
isso então a próxima turma vai ser dia
14 de setembro online e a ao vivo e
aquele descontinho Maroto de 15% tá na
descrição aqui e também vai rolar mais
uma quinta edição do curso de pensamento
crítico analítico comigo e com dudu
eh bom a gente rodou isso várias edições
Já e agora a próxima vai ser no dia 24
de agosto então se você quer aprender
como conectar um pouquinho os
indicadores financeiros aí com as
intervenções que você faz no produto
cola com nós eu de boa
Agora sim bora lá pra pauta Bora
[Música]
lá bom acho que a gente já falou aqui
algumas vezes sobre como que a meta tem
investido muito mais na segunda geração
do hban do que na primeira né seja
investimentos em PR em eventos etc até
para quem acompanha o Instagram da do
meta eles fizeram uma série de Event
eventos Pocket shows assim onde que você
tinha que guardar o celular na entrada e
gravar e filmar tudo com o seu com o seu
riban é então assim você não não
precisava se preocupar mais de ter
querendo ver um show e ter alguém com a
Caraca de um celular né na sua frente eu
falei disso lá atrás lembra quando eu
quando eu fiz tá vendo Aí
ó enfim mas isso tem surtido efeito né
ah num papo recente o CEO da da luxotic
lá né que é a empresa dona de várias
marcas entre elas a própria rban
comentou que a nova versão já vendeu
mais em seis meses Lembrando que ele foi
lançado em outubro ali em 6 meses já
vendeu mais do que a primeira geração em
quase 2 anos e uma das coisas que ele
falou é que cara as expectativas das
pessoas agora para V2 tá muito mais
claro né então isso tem ajudado a gente
evoluir o produto tal as pessoas
entenderem Como utilizar e etc
e tem rolado aí um
burburinho de que a meta vai comprar uma
participação na
esotica e enfim e também tem todo o Boom
de ai aí que já já eu comento como tá
sendo meu uso que agora a funcionalidade
tá liberada para mim de Ai eu já já
conto aqui minhas peripécias de ai é
inclusive esse negócio da Meta comprar
uma participação é ontem eu ou hoje não
lembro eu vi que o Google entrou na
jogada também
então parece que tem competição né Não
dá não dá para ver o primo rico fazendo
o negócio que quer fazer também então
esse mundo das Big Tex é essa graça mas
aí como é que tá sendo o qu não pera aí
eu não entendi o qu o Google quer
comprar uma parte da é do mesmo surgiu o
rumor de que a meta que é comprar
eh uma participação na na SL luxottica
luxottica não sei qual jeito de falar Eh
o Google também estaria interessado Olha
só e burburinhos da Internet pois é mas
enfim vamos lá pra parte mais
interessante que é o tirar a primeira
dúvida liberou para você porque você tá
nos Estados Unidos ou libero já tava
funcionando no Brasil não não Libero
L cara Eu pisei nos States eu já tava no
programa Beta deles né todas as a
maioria das atualizações etc mas a dei
especificamente nunca tinha liberado
então só então é capaz só funciona aí
não não Então esse é o ponto no início
sim mas eu
vi eu tô num grupo no Reddit aqui que da
galera que usa e tals nas últimas duas
semanas vários lugares em vários cantos
do mundo tendo tipo mandado que tá
liberado sem usar VPN você pode fazer o
o a paradinha lá sempre dá para dar um
jeito né sempre dá mas mesmo sem usar a
VPN tem alguns países tipo um cara
postou na Argentina um outro na em
Londres
eh Enfim então eu acho que eles estão
começando a a liberar um pouco mais
assim mas assim para mim eu acho que
definitivamente foi Ele identificou meu
IP identificou minha parada minha ge
location tá nos States aqui terra terra
do tio San tá liberado liberado justo é
e agora com essa treta aí também que
teve com Ai aqui no Brasil já a gente
fala também não sei se eles vão liberar
tão cedo no Brasil direto É porque Pens
mas vamos ver também se se você agora
que do tipo já liberou uma vez para mim
quando eu voltar pro Brasil falar esse
cara aí já tem e tal vou deixar liberar
no banco mudou né agora você tá com
enable is ai enabled
Yes Pois é di como é que tá sendo o uso
aí dessa brincadeira cara primeira coisa
é um efeito muito bacana assim sabe que
eu entrei abri o app lá e ele Já Pim tá
liberado para você veja aqui como
funciona não sei o qu e tal Como que
você pode utilizar tem um ponto
importante que você tem que liberar
ele antes você não precisava liberar o
acesso à
câmera do seu celular e aí agora ele tem
ele a câmera sei lá ele pede para uma
autorização diferente lá para ele para
ele tirar as imag porque ele tira uma
imagem né você você vai e pergunta para
ele he meta look and me blá blá blá o
que quer que você queira Mas ele faz
isso com a câmera do do óculos né É mas
ele pede uma autorização lá se ele pode
tipo tirar fotos e do tipo enfim é um
treta lá
e E aí cara é isso assim porque E aí
então pô essa é uma parada legal e e é
um efeito bacana de você tirar lá
perguntar as coisas e cara A precisão é
muito boa assim eu fiquei espantado com
várias situações que eu já utilizei
assim e ele cara trouxe muito real assim
o que que era tá ligado por exemplo T um
uso útil ou só guim até agora não Então
esse é um dos Esse é um dos pontos que
esse é um dos pontos que eu vou falar
pro meu
uso ainda o uso que eu tô fazendo agora
é de nerdola sabe hoje tipo ah quero
testar isso aqui Ah vê se in cheque isso
aqui V se identifica isso aqui o que que
é isso o que que eu tô olhando Tá então
pro meu uso ainda não tá assim então
ainda preciso ver como que vai ser o uso
o uso diário mesmo assim se tiver
ativado se é prático mesmo no dia a
dia parte ruim duas coisinhas assim que
tem me incomodado eh ele ainda é meio
lento o processamento dele não
é não é lá dos bons então não tá fazendo
um device né ele tá mandando pro seu
celular o seu celular tá mandando pro
servidor o servidor tá processando e
devolvendo isso né É então assim ele
demora ele tira o processo lá e manda
então às vezes demora um pouquinho então
às vezes é literalmente mais fácil pegar
o celular e pesquisar o que quer que
seja do que de fato usar ele agora uma
outra parte que é a parte que eu não
curti muito é que nem sempre ele avisa
que ele não conseguiu analisar sacou
Então você vai clica lá ele dá o
barulhinho de que tá processando Mas ele
tem hora que ele responde fala cara não
consegui tirar a foto aqui não consegui
identificar isso não consegui entender o
que você falou mas ele tem hora que ele
simplesmente tipo processa e não
responde [__] nenhuma sabe é tipo o o
error randl que tá faltando ali né de
tipo deu timeout nessa conexão nessa
esperando resposta E aí ele não te avisa
disso Exatamente exatamente Faz um faz
um teste para mim e postando Arena tipo
Aproveita que você está nos States e vê
se ele tipo se você olhando para uma
placa ele traduz porque eu acho um Case
muito legal ass para pessoas que não
falam outras línguas assim a gente se
aproximar né de cara a pessoa não
precisa fazer falar mas ela consegue
aqui Navegar num lugar com isso né Posta
lá no no Insta do Arena boa vou fazer
vou fazer vou fazer esse teste e aí uma
outra coisa legal é que ele vai salvando
as as imagens que você perguntou que
você falou com ele ele vai ele vai
salvando essas imagens então depois você
consegue olhar todas as na hora que ele
que ele fez o c o capturou a imagem ele
salva aquela imagem e fica disponível
para você num num dos no lá todo tudo
que ele o que ele tirou e qual foi a
resposta dele em cima daquilo ali sabe e
e dá para ter interações que não sejam
Me fale sobre essa imagem essa foto tipo
você pode usar como você usa uma ultra
llm se quiser perguntar qualquer coisa
aleatória pode pode pode legal uhum boa
massa rola sim
e eu acho que tem um tem um gancho legal
aí pro pro Segundo assunto que é o do
lama 3.1 né que é a nova versão do da
llm do Facebook que você falou cara ele
é meio lento então às vezes é melhor
pegar o celular e tal
e hoje a meta anunciou o novo modelo
deles né o lema 3.1 que é simplesmente
um modelo de 45 bilhões de parâmetros
então é um modelo gigantesco Mas eles
atualizaram os modelos também de de oito
de 8 bit de 70 b e eles falam lá no no
no press release que inclusive o negócio
que eles vão trabalhar mais é on device
models e modelos multimodais ali né
então os modelos on device claramente
tem um uso aqui que é cara como que você
faz esse processamento
eh no aparelho para esse retorno ser
mais rápido né para para quem tá usando
um um óculos por exemplo mas falando aí
principais coisas do do Lhama 3.1 né
Acho que o ponto principal aqui
é que ele é um modelo a galera chama de
Frontier Model né então é um modelo de
ponta open source é o primeiro grande
modelo de ponta open source tipo os
modelos anteriores da própria meta eles
eram bastante capazes mas eles eram
capazes na linha
e 3.5 né chat PT 3.5 esse modelo pelo
menos ali nos benchmarks ele rivaliza
com rivaliza e até melhor em vários
cenários do que o for0 eh e até que o
Claud o Claud 3.5 sonnet que tem tem
sido dito como o melhor modelo atual né
então eu acho que essa é a parada mais
impressionante é o modelo de ponta
liberado com todos os pesos liberados
que as pessoas podem usar para que elas
quiserem podem fazer aplicações
comerciais podem treinar outros modelos
eh pode gerar dado sintético pode criar
modelos menores então agora tá na mão da
G
para usar um [__] modelo [__] do jeito
que quiser então céu é o limite né vamos
dizer Pois é cara é Vamos ver aí o que
que que que vai acontecer né mas alguns
dados interessantes aí que é legal de
falar dessa release que inclusive né o
zberg postou um testão lá né falando
sobre isso mas vamos lá acho que o
primeiro item é que essa versão ainda é
só texto né não é não tem a parte de de
im ainda apesar de nos papers lá eles
ter falado tanto da tradução de do tipo
que ele é capaz de identificar e etc e
gerar texto mas mas ainda não o a janela
ali pelo que eles falaram e nos testes é
que ele consegue processar uma parada de
até um livro de até umas 50 páginas e
tudo mais
eh é mais não é a janela de de 128k de
contexto eu acho que é mais é mais do
que isso eu não lembro quanto é 128 é é
cara pelo que eu vi era era isso de um
página de uns 50 Mas enfim por al é
Enfim uma parada que duas coisas
curiosas aliás uma eu vou deixar pro
final ali porque já tem a ver até com o
nessa linha Aliás não já vou falar aqui
uma coisa é eles não compartilharam de
onde estão vindo os dados do treinamento
né que é aquela essa discussão eterna aí
do Tipo pô tão usando os dados inclusive
eh deu uma A treta que deu lá no Brasil
foi disso né que eles estavam
utilizando os dados do Brasil também e
etc e aí rolou maior treta lá com
pediram para isso eles cancelaram
bloquearam né não estão treinando com os
dados na da rede das redes sociais
Instagram Facebook afins no Brasil
eh mas um outro dado relevante é que
eles usaram dados sintéticos para fine
tunning né E aí a gente até já falou
você falou em algum episódio sobre dados
sintéticos e até para relembrar a galera
aqui sobre sobre esse sobre esse item
eh são Dados meio gerados né são dado
fake e ali
e mas que normalmente é uma parada que
não é muito aconselhada né assim
principalmente na parte do treinamento e
tudo mais e eles assim utilizaram e
falaram que deram que deu super bem e um
outro ponto também que eles falaram lá
no no no no artigo aqui no press release
que eles não separaram lá qual foi a
porcentagem de fato do que foi teste de
que foi dado sintético e o que que foi
dado real
eh e eles
também lançaram o os modelos menores né
Eh é eles atualizaram né o de 8
atualizaram exato É e e só falar sobre
dado sintético né rapidinho tipo a gente
tá falando aqui e Pode parecer que o
modelo é pior porque ele tá treinando em
dados gerados Ali pela própria máquina
né e cara não porque a gente com certeza
vai ver isso nas próximas atualizações
seja do dos modelos da Open ai seja no
nos modelos das outras empresas que já é
meio que consenso entre os especialistas
que simplesmente não existe dado
suficiente mais para ser treinado em em
algumas iterações desses modelos então
vai ter que ser produzido mesmo dado
sintético Então esse é um caminho que
Muito provavelmente todos eles vão e E
no fim existem nbch Marks para depois
discutir a qualidade do output desses
modelos né então Independente de como
eles estão sendo treinados ali se no fim
os benchmark estiverem melhorando né e
obviamente a gente como sociedade ele
tem que cada vez mais evoluir os
benchmarks que a gente tem porque a
gente sabe também que esses modelos
estão ficando cada vez melhor em passar
em prova do que e não só no uso real mas
é algo que vai acontecer com todos
provavelmente pois é pois é e aí o
último item também interessante né
Principalmente por também ser uma parada
open source e tudo mais eles lançaram
uma série de ferramentas também para
ajudar a identificar quando dá a
resposta em devida ou resposta com
cunhos
eh com questões com
questões enfim problemáticas e tals
eh Enfim então e e eles também fizeram
eh uma rfc né uma request for comments
ali pr pra api do Lhama então eles estão
estão chamando de lam stack né então a
ideia deles é tornar cada vez mais fácil
e acessível para desenvolvedores usarem
os modelos que já tá acessível em todos
os principais Cloud providers ali já tá
no huging faces e tal mas eles também
estão começando a trabalhar nisso e tão
pedindo contribuição da comunidade de
como a gente pode tornar esse set de
apis melhor aqui para você né então tão
abraçados na linha de ser o a opção open
source desse dessa nova plataforma
computacional né
então bem bem legal assim as opções que
estão sendo dadas e o caminho que eles
estão seguindo Pois é e acho que por
último né você já citou por alto mas
rolou aí a notícia da Meta com Brasil
essa semana de que eles estaram ali o
treinamento das Ferramentas de ji no
Brasil então rolou ali uma e uma questão
com a anpd né que a Agência Nacional de
Proteção de dados a meta não tava
seguindo eh a as recomendações da
agência e aí eles ficaram eh poderiam
estar tomando uma multa que eu não
lembro o valor aqui exato mas uma multa
alta diária E aí o que eles decidiram
foi por hora eh parar o treinamento com
dados dos usuários Bras brasileiros né E
também tirar do ar e as ferramentas de
DNI que já estavam disponíveis no Brasil
né Talvez um risco aí do do seu R meta
não funcionar no Brasil seja esse
né mas por exemplo tinha a ferramenta de
stickers do WhatsApp e tal e que já tava
liberada e eles deram rzinho aí enquanto
eles resolvem essa questão a m era de R
50.000 por dia de não comply aqui né
imagina isso aí comprando fazendo
translate disso aí em fralda
pô é a sua métrica de conversão agora né
Tudo vira
fralda é duro amigo Ai é isso é
[Música]
isso segundo conteúdo de hoje é sobre a
Netflix a gente vai comentar um pouco
sobre a reportagem inside Netflix Bat on
Advanced video encoding feita pelo the
verge que a gente sempre indica aqui né
um dos nossos sites favoritos aqui de
Notícias Tech e só para dar um contexto
rápido de como que eu fui parar nesse
conteúdo né [__] Mega nerd aqui de vídeo
o negócio eu trabalhei com streaming por
alguns anos no esporte interativo né
então até mais do que o Artur porque eu
entrei mais na parte de operação e tal
uma época e por causa disso até hoje eu
tenho muito Interesse nessa parte
técnica de distribuição de vídeo mas
esse texto não faz sentido só para quem
é nerd de vídeo por isso que a gente
trouxe aqui é um assunto legal assim
sobre a empresa e evolução porque o
Ponto Central do texto é falar sobre
toda a tecnologia de encoding que é
basicamente a forma como você compacta
um vídeo que a Netflix desenvolveu ao
longo do tempo e todas as Sacadas que
eles foram tendo para tornar isso cada
vez mais eficiente e melhor tanto pro
usuário né super importante mas também
pro bolso da empresa né todo mundo no
fim quer ali melhorar o seu panel então
por exemplo no início eles encod avam o
vídeo todo um filme uma série inteira de
o mesmo jeito usando uma mesma técnica
usando as mesmas ferramentas E aí com o
tempo eles foram percebendo que eles
poderiam encodar cada frame ou cada
bloco de frames de um vídeo de uma forma
diferente dependendo do que fosse então
se fosse uma animação eles encod avam de
um jeito se fosse uma cena dentro de uma
série eles encava de outro se fosse uma
cena de ação de outro então eles foram
caminhando para ser cada vez mais
eficientes quase que frame a frame ali
dos conteúdos que a gente assiste tem
várias outras coisas aqui que eu achei
interessante mas queria ver também você
meu querido Artur que que você curtiu aí
desse texto cara eu acho que foi
uma aula de vários it outas coisas se o
texto é longo tá até para já deixar que
o tto é Longuinho é longinho a AF fim de
ler o texto é longo mas é legal ver
vários conceitos do dia a dia de produto
assim de coisas que a gente vive falando
aqui nos Episódios acho que uma das
primeiras coisas para mim que marcou
muito foi o lance dele do de como que
eles mudaram a a tática deles né que é o
lance de revisitar o produto assim que
que é algo que a gente tem que estar
fazendo sempre né que é isso eles encod
avam tudo e aí depois você fala não cara
dá para encodar [__] frame a frame aqui
ou dá para fazer uma outra coisa ou dá
para colocar mais inteligência aqui para
tipo pegar coisas específicas contexto
específicos categorias específicas de
vídeo então e acho que é isso né Eh
nosso trabalho em produto assim a gente
às vezes acaba entrando muito Deep assim
né entrando muito ficando muito no dia a
dia esquece de dar o o o passo para trás
ali para pensar no no macro né assim
falar cara tá bom a gente que é até uma
coisa que o Lucas falou no no último
episódio que a gente gravou aqui que é
uma parada que eu sempre provoco
qualquer pessoa que trabalha comigo que
faz parte dos dos meus times que é o e
si né E se a gente fizesse essa parada
de outro jeito né será que vai ficar
melhor eh vai ficar mais barato vai
ficar mais prático vai dar mais insights
pra gente então acho que são itens isso
é isso foi uma parada que eu achei muito
muito legal assim de de ver Total total
e isso que você falou do e si é
interessante porque tem algo relacionado
a isso que é o é um dos eu não lembro
seu um dos presidentes da Netflix é um
dos diretores lá no no conteúdo tem que
revisitar aqui eh mas que ele fala que o
negócio foi importante para eles aí
olhando até para novos conteúdos né Live
games é pensar com a cabeça diferente do
que eles tinham para streaming de vod né
que é o conteúdo vde m né que a gente
fala e eu acho que é bem isso que você
falou tipo é o ICI e e um ICI que se
provoca mais de tipo não é ECI em cima
do que a gente já fez pode ser também
pode embasar mas é um ECI diferente né e
é eles até falam cara a gente consegue
fazer encoding frame a frame de vod
porque você sabe exatamente qual é a
próxima coisa que vai vir num Esporte ao
vivo por exemplo no WWE que eles vão
passar a transmitir você não sabe o que
é o próximo frame que vem então você tem
que se provocar ainda mais de tipo
talvez todos os breakthroughs que você
teve de para chegar na tecnologia aqui
vão ter que ter outros breakthroughs
agora para pros próximos passes né total
e esse aí é um outro tipo de desafio
interessante de falar né eles tinham um
um contexto né que era o lançar o os
vídeos On Demand etc e agora quando eles
A Estratégia do Business de crescer do
dois dois momentos né teve um primeiro
que era lá em 2015 que era assim cara
vamos pro mundo inteiro então [__] a
gente vai lidar com lugares que tem
internet muito pior e tudo mais e tal
aparelhos piores né aparelhos piores e
etc Então tá bom precisamos rever isso
aqui precisamos ver como que a gente
adapta e uma outra evolução do produto e
evolução da Estratégia né que é o
aspecto de Tá bom agora a gente vai para
para tipo ao vivo que agora é um
contexto [__] muito diferente e eles
até citam de quando eles meio que
tentaram seguir a mesma coisa que eles
fizeram no vod lá no lançamento no ao
vivo do casamento as cegas né do
episódio do reencontro lá do casamento
as cegas na gringa deu pau ficou deu ma
problema eles falaram cara a gente não
pode fazer a mesma coisa né como que a
gente reinventa isso aqui muda porque
Putz agora a gente vai entrar numa outra
Seara né e eu fiquei lembrando lembrando
disso aqui de da época que eu trabalhava
com micromobilidade na yello do aspecto
primeiro a gente lançou as bikes e
depois a gente lançou os patinetes que
era outro contexto sacou era apesar de
ser um veículo também mas era um outro
contexto de uso e tudo mais tinha outras
coisas envolvidas até mesmo na na na tem
bice depois quando no no bike do Bike
Itú quando a gente lançou as bikes
elétricas também era tipo bike normal
era uma coisa bike elétrica foi um outro
jeito então é isso cara como Reinventar
o produto baseado nessa evolução do
produto é is você precisa ter olhar você
passa a ter olhares Diferentes né para
as paradas Total eu acho que essa foi
umaas paras que eu achei mais
interessante assim fazendo essa conexão
com o dia a dia de produto que é mesmo
uma empresa do tamanho e competência
técnica da Netflix [__] eles
tecnicamente são muito [__] tem
dificuldade em fazer coisas que são a
adjacentes né nem fazer um negócio
completamente diferente que é exatamente
o que você falou cara fazer patinete é
um negócio adjacente é você fazer
bicicleta fazer bicicleta elétrica é
adjacente a fazer bicicleta você não
tava fazendo bicicleta e foi fazer avião
tá ligado é você foi fazer um negócio
próximo ali e é difícil porque as
competências que você desenvolveu como
companhia para te fazer aquela primeira
coisa muito bem não não necessariamente
vão ser as competências para fazer
aquela segunda coisa muito bem e eu acho
que tem um um um exercício de humildade
até aqui que eles falam que é cara
quando você vai fazer algo novo não
adianta você otimizar de cara porque
você não sabe fazer então não adianta
você querer já otimizar para ter o
melhor custo a melhor margem do negócio
obviamente no negócio que você pode se
dar liberdade disso né então começa com
os defs do negócio faz o padrão da
indústria ali e depois você vai
aprendend a otimizar com o vod mesmo foi
isso né eles cara fazia o encoding da
indústria depois eles foram otimizando
ajudaram a criar codex novos ali junto
com a indústria e e depois chegou nesse
breakthrough de cara você gente fosse
frame a frame fazer isso daqui tipo [__]
fizemos frame a frame mas eh tem
cenários aqui que isso não ficou tão
legal qualquer a próxima coisa mas eu
acho achei isso muito da hora de não é
porque você é muito [__] em uma coisa
que você necessariamente vai ser [__]
numa coisa muito próxima né É então isso
é muito da hora para uma empresa tipo
gig como a Netflix né brother e desses
desafios novos né é curioso que eles tão
duas coisas ao mesmo tempo né de
desafios novos assim é claramente
expansão né da base e tal que é o Live a
gente já falou aqui várias vezes né do
das coisas de ao vivo de esporte que
eles estão fazendo mas não só Esporte n
eles fizeram especial de comédia ao vivo
que você falou do casamento à cegas
então eles estão experimentando ali e
obviamente Porque quando eles tiverem
que fazer esports Live e fazer um
negócio tipo WWE que é a maior audiência
da emissora que ele passa nos Estados
Unidos do não sei dos últimos quantos
anos tá ligado todo ano é é
constantemente a maior audiência eles
tem que fazer bem então ele já tem que
ter dominado pelo menos parte disso para
na hora que chegar o prime time ali eles
eles fazerem super bem e tem jogos né
que é outra parada ali porque o jogo
eles fazem jogo por streaming hoje é
Netflix né Então você vai lá is vai no
servidor e volta pro pra sua TV ou pro
seu celular só que a Apesar dele ser
próximo do conteúdo Live ali tem uma
questão que não tem no conteúdo que é o
input do jogador né É você apertar
botões botar para um lado pro outro que
é um outro desafio completamente
diferente ali de encoding aí tem um um
podcast muito legal do do The verge
também o Decoder com um dos dos ceos da
da Netflix que ele fala um pouquinho
sobre esses desafios de jogos e essa
dificuldade de você ter que encodar
diferente e para onde que eles vão com
isso não a gente deixa o link aí nos no
na descrição do push também Uhum E a
última coisa que antes da gente
finalizar esse bloco uma parada que você
até falou né que eles setaram trouxeram
novos codex e tudo mais e eles também
treinaram modelos em parceria junto com
uma universidade né da Califórnia para
desenvolver do tipo usando machine
learning etc novos modelos eh para para
analisar né a qualidade dos vídeos e etc
e o mais maneiro é que eles deixaram
esse modelo open source depois né então
é legal ver esses movimentos assim da
parceria né entre a parte mais talvez
não é te não só teórica mas acadêmica
acadêmica a parte mais acadêmica mas com
uma aplicação Mega prática e que depois
voltou pro mercado como um todo e cara
todo mundo passou a usar né E que é uma
uma parada que eu vejo que é várias
empresas fazem um pouco isso né próprio
airbnb quando quando teve lançou o Lor
lá para para animações e tals Então cara
É legal ver esse tipo de coisa né total
e nesse ponto né eles fizeram um filme
de 12 minutos feito justamente para
servir de benchmark para codex e modelos
de incode liberal tipo está aqui
filmamos gravamos isso aqui é o novo
indust Standard para vocês validar e
essas coisas e essa parada de liberar
pros outros também eu acho que conecta
com o assunto do primeiro bloco do
Facebook que é cara o Facebook não tá
liberando os modelos g e open source
porque eles são bonzinhos tá ligado
puramente É porque cara vai ter um monte
de gente construindo em cima disso
tornando esse negócio melhor esse
negócio volta pro Facebook tipo um
produto melhor para eles usarem Além
disso treina pessoas que eventualmente
vão vão trabalhar no Facebook no futuro
né mano então
cria tecnologia você dá na mão na galera
essa tecnologia vira standar da
indústria cara quando você for recrutar
todo mundo usa sua tecnologia sabe isso
aconteceu com n coisas em plataformas de
dados acho tem vários exemplos assim mas
tem tem muita coisa que isso aconteceu
então a roda se fecha aqui entre o nosso
segundo e o nosso primeiro conteúdo é
isso né cara é conexão aqui isso e bora
lá pros produtos da semana Bora lá
[Música]
Ah então começa Aí você me dizendo qual
que foi o seu produto da última semana
cara o produto da última semana já tem
foi até já vou até acabar falando de
outras pessoas aqui também mas foi
Amazon né Principalmente porque tava que
estou aqui nos States e aqui tem o prime
de verdade assim sabe
né o prime full tinha coisa aqui com eu
até ache esse ano melhorzinho do que o
dos outros anos aqui no Brasil mas não
tem comparação Unos é mano tinha coisa
com literalmente sei lá 50 70% de
desconto tá ligado e coisas é não é tipo
rebarba do estoque né nego é é então
[__] foi foi massa então e aí um outro
que aí pô eu sempre uso bastante quando
eu estou por aqui que é o stock x que
basicamente para quem quem quer uma
referência do stockx é tipo dropper no
Brasil o dropper meio que copiaram eles
eu não sei é
o cara é para comprar tênis ou itens
mais raros assim coisas específicas
coisa de sneak head é mas eles tem não
só tem bolsa tem um monte de coisa
também assim mas pô eu eu
particularmente gosto muito al ele tem
uma parada lá que você pode dar o bid no
no tênis ao invés ao invés de pagar o
preço full que tá lá você pode negociar
então tem alas paradinhas que são são
legais assim e e daqui a pouco também
mostro qual que foi o o colecionável o
tênis colecionável que eu comprei dessa
vez boa eu vou aproveitar e falar o meu
aqui porque também tem a ver com o prime
Day então só para fungir um pouco e eu
usei muito Twitter e telegram para ver
as promoções do Prime Day então no
Twitter principalmente o @ chatd
promoções ali e tem um outro que eu
esqueci agora e
no no telegram um canal tô até abrindo
aqui para ver que é o caçadores de
ofertas então eu eu sou sempre fico
visitando esse site de promoções né o
get try hardMOB e tal e aí eu fui na
nessa linha de ficar acompanhando ali
mais live com por esses canais durante o
prime MD e foi legal cara é E aí sigo
aqui tipo V e Mexe
eh dá aquela apertadinha no botão do
consumismo né [__] esse negócio aqui que
eu não precisava mas tá num preço bom
deixa eu comprar e de casa nova né dá
vontade de comprar tudo novo também pois
é pois
é muito bom e os nossos ouvintes aqui
mandaram Prime o Amazon também a Amanda
o Henrique
eh teve vários
produtos hoje físicos mesmo a Karina
Karina Sato e o pessoal lá da docket
mandou a bblend todo todo mundo tem uma
bblend agora e ABL de
garrafinha exato É eles lançaram uma
versão de garrafinha disso n você tem a
máquina eu tenho a máquina e aí há um
tempo atrás eles lançaram uma garrafinha
também para tipo simular a a máquina né
e galera tá usando bastante o andrezão
mandou um jogo de tabuleiro Azul ele
falou que jogou bastante Achei que era
da Azul aão Pan é [__] o Andrezinho
mandou o crun roll lá de Anime e tudo
mais O Lucas mandou snowflake falou que
a função nova de ai lá deles ajudou
bastante tá muito mais fácil para para
gerar as queries e tudo mais o Glauco
mandou o Vivino a Anana mandou o strava
o Victor mandou o Squad Busters O Caco
mandou o daqui
a a pilon que também tá em mudança ela
também tá na mesma trad que nós mandou
que não foram instalar internet lá na
casa dela ainda mas ela usou tá usando
super bem o net Claro wi-fi lá e tá
rolando bem então ela falou cara
tando Então são esses aí bastante coisa
aí mandem continuem mandando pra gente
semana a gente sabe que a gente pede em
cima da hora e da gravação mas sempre
que vocês lembrarem mandem pra gente lá
no Instagram do prod Arena no meu
Instagram no Instagram do Artur que a
gente traz
[Música]
aqui E com isso a gente encerra o
programa dessa semana
então recadinhos da Paróquia aqui de
sempre né segue a gente se você ouviu Se
encaminharam esse programa aqui para
você e você ainda não segue a gente no
seu tocador de Podcast Favorito vai lá
dá cinco estrelinhas deixa um comentário
agora no Spotify você pode deixar
comentários lá mas você pode deixar
comentário no YouTube também no substack
todo e qualquer engajamento que você
fizer ajuda demais o podcast a crescer a
treinar os algoritmos ali das redes
falando ó tem gente gostando disso vou
indicar para mais gente então Ajuda nós
lá E você também indica ouviu algo aqui
que você acha que alguém que você
conhece vai curtir manda lá fala ó ouve
lá popo na arena podcast aques dois
meninos é legal então indica aí se fala
aí
inclusive A gente esqueceu de comemorar
né a gente chegou mais uma vez ali no
top 30 do Apple podcasts ol aí agora tem
chegar no top 20 é a missão do noss
indicar mais uma pessoa se cada um
indicar cada um que ouvi esse programa
indicar mais uma pessoa para ouvir cara
a gente chega no top 20 Certeza certeza
certeza certeza então Ajuda nós e segue
a gente nas redes né a reclamação a a o
recadinho de sempre @x @arthur Close
comk @ product Arena Então segue nós lá
e é isso até semana que vem Artur até
meu caro ah a última dado importante
aqui né ah é vamos lá qual que é o
update do tamanho da Eve Pera aí que tô
aqui ó a i essa semana ela tá do tamanho
de um pinguim ou de
um de o um combo de
panquecas combo de cara completamente
aleatório esse combo de panquecas Pois é
não combo é um monte de Pan mon de
panqueca empilhada não faz sentido
nenhum essa analogia com isso encerramos
panquecas e pinguins encerramos até a
semana que vem panquecas e pinguins até